all right number four the toronto sun
has infuriating
news really putting it mildly this is
out of canada
it says peel health has issued
guidelines to parents
instructing them to keep any children
who've been sent home because a
classmate has tested positive for kova
19
isolated a separate room from all other
family members for
14 days now
these are not even sick kids kids who
are in a class
with a kid who is sick isolated in
solitary confinement in their homes for
14 days
the severe guidelines which apply even
to small children who are dismissed from
child
care are being criticized by experts as
harmful and not supported by science
this is cruel punishment for a child
this is dr suzanne richardson
uh says uh cruel punishment of a child
especially for younger children four to
ten years old
shutting a child off from their parents
and siblings for up to 14 days in this
manner
could produce significant and
long-lasting emotional and psychological
effects
well yeah the article says the handout
distributed at peel region schools
explains if your child does not have any
symptoms
the child must self-isolate which means
stay in a separate room
eat in a separate room apart from others
use a separate bathroom if possible
the handout also says if the child must
leave their room they should wear a mask
and stay two meters apart from any from
others
any other children in the household not
only must be both separated from their
siblings but also stay home for 14 days
now i can't even keep reading this
it it is that uh
infuriating to me if you would actually
do this to your child
put them in solitary confinement isolate
them
this is what they're talking about in a
separate room for
two weeks no physical
contact with anyone in the family
i mean you can't even do this to
prisoners
this would be considered human rights
abuse if you did it to a prisoner
you do it to your child if you would do
that to your child
because you're afraid they're gonna get
you sick then you do and i do not say
this lightly
but you do not deserve to have children
you should have your children taken from
you
you should be in you should be
imprisoned yourself you should be the
one in solitary confinement
if you would do that to your kid there
is no excuse for it
i don't care i i don't i don't want to
hear the excuse
yeah i mean you could tell me that you
know you have pre-existing conditions
and all this kind of i'm sympathetic to
that
but there is no excuse for doing that to
your child period
i would literally rather die i would
actually rather die i would certainly
rather
take the extremely minimal risk
even if it wasn't minimal let's say i
was in a high-risk group
and they told me well your kid might be
sick so stick them in a room for two
weeks
you know your four-year-old child put
them in a room for two weeks by
themselves
never go closer if they come out of the
hallway make sure they're in a mess
never come closer than two meters from
them
yeah you're high risk and if you don't
do that you might get sick and die
my response would be okay i'm gonna get
sick and die then i guess
because that is simply not an option
and the thing is you know you you read
this and you think
man there's no way parents would
actually do this
these are these are insane quote-unquote
public health officials
who don't have who probably childless
themselves childless alone and miserable
trying to impose their misery on
everybody else okay
and and it's it's a they're saying this
they're they're detached from the issue
themselves they don't know anything
about kids they don't understand
uh but but a parent parent wouldn't
actually do this
you love your child you would never do
this to them that's what you want to
think
but then if this is any judge of it uh
you know if this tells us anything i'm
looking at
you know the the the link to this
article
on twitter and i'm reading some of the
comments hundreds of comments
and many of them are from parents
saying that they have done this or they
ease or they would do it
they're per they're prepared to do it
they are prepared to absolutely
psychologically and emotionally
devastate their children
in ways that they may never recover from
they are prepared to do that
in order to keep themselves safe
every single one of these parents unfit
and don't deserve to have they don't
love their kids
you do not love your child if you do
that to your kid period
this is not an exaggeration when i say
lifelong damage
i mean think about that yeah when you
were a kid you were sent to your room
for a couple hours right
at most i mean usually it's you probably
had to really earn
you know an hour or more in your room um
two weeks no absolutely not
hey listen hit the subscribe button do
it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated